واكدت احصاءات قناه ايران انترناشونال ان
80 مدرسه على الاقل تواجه ازمه تسمم بسبب
تعرض طالباتها لهجوم كيماوي وسط اهمال بعض
مسؤول المدارس تقديم مساعدات لازمه
التلميذات وبعد التحقق من مقاطع الفيديو
يبدو ان رقعه الارهاب البيولوجي تتسع كما
نشاهد في هذه الخريطه حيث شملت محافظه
طهران العاصمه الارستان خرسان الرضويه
فارس واصفهان
واردبيل وهمزان واذربيجان الشرقيه وايضا
الغربيه في الاعلى في السياق قالت رئيسه
مركز الصحه غرب الاهواز انه ظهرت على
التلميذات اعراض مثل احمرار الوجه والبشره
وضيق التنفس ومن جهته اشار نائب رئيس
جامعه الاحواز للعلوم الطبيه الى ارتفاعي
حصيله المتسممات في مدرسه خيام حيث تسممت
تلميذ على الاقل 10 منهن تحت تم السماح
لهن بمغادره المستشفى ننوه قبل المتابعه
الى الاخبار العاجله التي وردت قبل قليل
نقلا عن خمنئي الذي اتهم جونات لانهم
المسؤولين عن جريمه تسميم الطالبات
واقر بانها جريمه لا تختفر
نتابع وطلبت المتحدثه الرسميه باسم مفوضيه
الامم المتحده الساميه لحقوق الانسان
رافيندا شمتساني بطاقات الحقائق للتعرف
على مرتكبي هذه الهجمات الكيماويه
ومعاقبتهم خاصه وان قضيه التسمم المتسلل
للفتيات ارتبطت بالجغرافيا السياسيه
لايران وامتدت الى عده مدن على حد تعبيرها